I don't feel so good theory man I don't
want to go oh please don't let me go
don't be afraid fact boy you have so
much to live for a new movie next year
and a whole franchise ahead of you I'm
sure you're gonna be fine all right
who's got the time rock or soul rock or
whatever bs were using to reverse this
thing
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where you don't have to worry about our
predictions spoiling the movie because
they're always so very very wrong
so Avengers endgame is coming out real
soon
sooner than I expected actually was it
just me or did the wait for this thing
go by super fast
I suppose it helps when you have six
other major superhero movie releases
crammed into the year that we spent
waiting anyway we all know how this is
gonna go right classic Avengers Assemble
one last time with the help of some new
friends they train they suit up they hop
through the time portals in the quantum
realm a bit and ultimately end up
fighting Thanos ant-man crawls up his
gut spans bada-bing bada-boom purple
shrek is defeated oh look we found
ourselves some shiny stones let's turn
back time and/or find dead people
trapped in the orange one yeah
everyone's back together except for
those that we lost along the way
let's scatter and/or destroy these
things roll credits oh wait spider-man
will return in literally three months
where's my paycheck Disney this sort of
excellent screenwriting deserves some
credit but all joking aside I hope it's
good I think part of me is a bit nervous
just because we all know that so many of
these characters are coming back and any
time you open up a world to time
vortexes and then also time stones that
are so overpowered and have the ability
to rewrite everything that came before
just worry that old cheapen the story
I'm all aboard for time-traveling
hijinks it's just when these movies are
so rooted in reality for so much of the
time once you start introducing multiple
devices that can retcon everything that
came before it becomes too easy it
starts to feel like nothing may really
matter retcons are kinda lame sometimes
which is why today I want to focus on
the deaths
that'll be permanent sure lots of the
snapping victims are gonna come back to
life but who in the main cast is gonna
stay dead at the end of endgame most
fans myself included consider it
incredibly likely that at least one of
our favorite heroes won't be going on to
phase four but I wasn't gonna take
consider it incredibly likely for an
answer so I scoured the MCU the comic
universes and the web looking for any
clues I could as to who may or may not
be continuing on afterwards and in the
process I feel reasonably confident as
to who will end up
the biggest surprise and permanent death
by the end of endgame so let's not waste
any more time this movie is about to
come out and let's just face it
I just love killing now it's escaped no
one's noticed that of all the snapping
victims the original Avengers all were
left untouched it's funny how a random
dispassionate culling of the world will
do something like that
the odds of all six people surviving
that coin flip would be like 1.5 percent
could it possibly be connected to the
fact that most of the original Avengers
contracts are coming up according to
Captain America himself last year around
the release of infinity war a lot of
their contracts were indeed expiring
after endgame a lot of our contracts are
threw myself down II hemsworth we all
kind of started well roughly at the same
time and I think we all through Avengers
four kind of wrap it up I don't know
what's next by 2019 that's that's that's
it with so many contracts that to expire
it seems like a good chance for Disney
to come run and start in with some new
actors so let's start by looking at all
these guys let's take out what I
consider two easy ones first
Hulk Will Survive actor Mark Ruffalo has
been very public that he's in a sixth
film contract and since cameos don't
count towards the total end game will be
only his fifth leaving at least one more
before the Jolly Green Giant goes away
Thor will also live not only have his
films been building in popularity and in
profits since he first hit the big
screen but from a story standpoint dying
would defeat his narrative purpose in
infinity war we see Thor at his lowest
of low points having lost most of the
Asgardians as well as the last of his
family and friends to Thanos his attacks
he's ready to lay down his life because
he feels like there's nothing left to
lose but on 1500 years old I'm only
alive because fate wants me alive he's
alone and by the end of the movie even
his belief in fate willing him to finish
off Thanos has let him down which means
that his endgame art will have to see
him making peace with the losses of his
ask something that'll be especially
powerful if this movie does indeed
involve a lot of time travel and then
moving on to find a new family people to
live with and for we already see his
important connection with Captain Marvel
in the trailers and we know based on the
avenge the Fallen posters that Valkyrie
from Thor Ragnarok is in here too so
already Thor is gonna be finding himself
new friends that'll help pave the way to
his new beginning
so those to me are the easy calls now
this may come as a surprise but of all
the characters and MCU I actually give
Black Widow Natasha Romanoff the lowest
chance of survival now some of you might
be screaming at the screen already how
can you say that Black Widow is gonna
die when we know that there's a black
widow movie coming out well according to
MCU cosmic and that hashtag show the
Black Widow movie is confirmed to be a
prequel set in the late 90s and early
2000s and if the Black Widow solo
project is gonna be a prequel well then
that leaves Natasha's fate totally up in
the air plus I'm sure if Black Widow
ultimately has a huge hero moment an
endgame it finally gets her the
recognition that she's been lacking as a
part of his team thereby making her solo
outing a much better bet and much more
exciting for audiences to seek out and
subscribe to Disney Plus in order to see
a consuming media in 2019 okay so she
can die but that doesn't necessarily
mean she has to die
so let's look at her narrative right now
she is in the perfect position to make a
huge self-sacrifice it's established
early on in the first Avengers movie
that Natasha has to clear and choosing
to sacrifice yourself to save half the
universe would certainly do that she
would also need to sacrifice herself for
a purpose that no one else is able to
fill I mean she describes herself as
someone with I have a very specific
skillset but most of those skills aren't
particularly helpful when you're
surrounded by gods and tech geniuses so
what does Black Widow have that's
different than all the rest well she has
a relationship with Bruce Banner think
about this Black Widow and Bruce banners
connection comes out of nowhere in age
of Ultron
she's the only person who's able to
control the appearance of the Hulk
I had to Ryu but I need the other guy
and while it's established in age of
Ultron it doesn't go away in future
movies either in Ragnarok black widows
Quinn jet recording reminds the audience
of their relationship
clearly this out of nowhere love
connection should be leading to a payoff
somewhere and what do we see in infinity
war Bruce struggling to unleash the Hulk
another plot line that seems pretty
random random until you consider the one
thing that could get bruised to lose his
cool losing Natasha she dies which
causes Bruce to Hulk out once again in
time for yet another round against
Thanos and this idea isn't just coming
out of nowhere
either Marvel likes to test out ideas
for the MCU in their comics first and in
secret Empire number 7 Natasha makes the
ultimate sacrifice to prevent Miles
Morales from fulfilling a prophecy of
killing Captain America now obviously
that's a completely different scenario
but what's important here is that Black
Widow has shown that she's willing to
sacrifice herself to stop the worst
possible timelines from playing out so
based on all of that I'd say she's dead
living on and that paywall gated prequel
heaven known as Disney Plus hello cap
well he hasn't been all that good at
keeping secrets
in October Captain America actor Chris
Evans tweeted quote officially wrapped
on Avengers four it was an emotional day
to say the least
playing this role over the last eight
years has been an honor thank you for
the memories eternally grateful
end quote if that doesn't sound like a
final farewell to the character well I
don't know what does director Joe Russo
tried to cover it up in a follow-up
interview saying up he tweeted that out
but little does he know he's not done
yet but Chris Evans seems pretty darn
eager to get out of the MCU and his
imminent departure keeps coming up in
the press he's gone on record saying
that he's eager to start directing and
it seems like Disney might be giving him
that opportunity again on Disney Plus
and here he is again at a press
conference for endgame talking like he's
done with the series
so his actor seems ready to move on his
contract seems ready to move on heck
Disney seems ready to move on but let's
take his advice and actually look at his
story arc because self-sacrifice is the
entire theme of his character in this
story Steve Rogers starts the series
ready to give his life for his country
and isn't allowed to that's the whole
gist of the First Avenger a lot of guys
getting killed over there kinda makes
you think twice about enlisting huh nope
he wants to enlist in the army
but can't but by the end of the first
movie he's not only the perfect soldier
he finally gets to make that sacrifice
he gives up his life in order to defeat
Red Skull no one expects him to wake up
from the ice but he does except now he's
no longer the idealist that he once was
family stability guy wanted all that
when in the ice 75 years ago I think
someone else came out in the modern day
he learns that his best friend Bucky's
been brainwashed into an assassin and
his subsequent quest to rescue him and
by proxy the only connection he has to
his past leads Steve to become
disillusioned and go rogue in civil war
this in turn gets him to change his
viewpoint on the world he no longer
stands for sacrificing for the good of
the many or the good of a faceless
country instead he's only focused on
sacrificing for the good of the
individual in infinity war we outright
hear him say we don't trade lies to
which vision response captain seventy
years ago you laid down your life to
save how many millions of people tell me
why is this any different it's not any
difference don't try to out logic a
supercomputer powered by a magic stone
their cap but Captain America has lost
everything and everyone that he's loved
since making that fateful decision to
self-sacrifice in his first movie and
the way the world has treated his best
friend in the aftermath of the war
hasn't made him particularly eager to
make that same sacrifice again which is
why when we enter endgame Captain
America has to give his own life to
complete his arc he has to make that
first sacrifice again only now he's
older and wiser and more experienced
he's knowing what he's getting himself
into and he's still willing to
anyway he's done everything to protect
his friend Bucky except for give him one
thing giving up his own life he's not
giving it up because he has nothing to
live for he's giving it up because he
wants to give his second chance at life
to a friend a friend who's been
brainwashed and persecuted for crimes
that he had no control in committing oh
and Bucky has four movies in the
contract so it's a good chance to hand
off the old Captain America baton or
shield which leads us to perhaps the
biggest question mark in my mind Tony
Stark
he can't talk cap without also covering
his counterpart in these movies Tony was
our first protagonist in the MCU way
back in 2007 iron man and since then
he's been one of the franchise's most
consistent characters with nine big
screen appearances which even beats out
Nick Fury's eight it's pretty darn great
if you're his actor Robert Downey jr.
who reportedly earns around 10 million
dollars plus 2.5 percent of profits for
each movie that he's in I mean I know
that Starks a billionaire but good old
RDJ ain't doing too bad for himself
either it's not all that hard to play
the role of a super-rich billionaire
when you're a super rich hundred
millionaire that said even though he's
an expensive addition to those cast
lists he's also a profitable one
according to adjusted ticket earnings
from box office mojo Marvel films that
include Tony Stark make an average of
four hundred and eight million dollars
while films without and make an average
of only 290 million and sure a lot of
those are the big team-up movies but
even when you remove them his movies
still average nearly seventy million
dollars more in earnings killing him off
from a financial standpoint at least
would be a bad decision that's business
what about what really matters killing
him off from a narrative standpoint
infinity war for all its characters sets
up a primary rivalry between Tony and
Thanos it seemed odd to me in a movie
where Thanos literally goes toe to toe
with gods and wizards that the one man
sano seems to truly respect his Tony as
he says himself they're both cursed with
knowledge you know me I do
you're not the only one cursed to
acknowledge they both see themselves as
protectors they're both arrogant they're
both powerful and smart from a
storytelling standpoint Thanos and Tony
are clearly foils of one another they
are meant to be a duality they are meant
to be compared and contrasted to show
off the deeper nuances of the characters
within each other and as such one other
key parallel that gets set up an
infinity war that narrative Lee should
pay off an endgame is a comparison of
them as fathers let me explain from a
story perspective Tony's already gone
through extensive character development
throughout the series when we first met
Tony he was selfish drunk and completely
unconcerned about the consequences of
his own actions as time has gone on
though we see him not only learn to work
well with others but also learned that
he isn't immortal seeing that there's a
wider universe of intergalactic threats
ready to take him down in Avengers is
what causes the paranoia that we see
manifested in Iron Man 3 nothing's been
the same since New York God's aliens
other dimensions I'm just a man in a can
but honey I can't sleep threat is
imminent and I have to protect the one
thing I can't live without that's you
the failure of Ultron knocks him down
yet another peg leading him to make the
variant on elec decision of signing away
his rights as a superhero over to the
government as part of the sokovia
accords in civil war oh that's Charles
Spencer by the way he want to make a
difference I suppose I mean we won't
know because we dropped the building on
him while we were kicking ass notice
that it's the death of a child that gets
him to change later on in spider-man
homecoming we see him slide into a
father role for Peter Parker and now
look at the opening scene for Tony an
infinity war he and pepper are having an
argument about kids last night I dreamt
we had a kid that you woke up in not
true we were expecting if you want to
have a kid I know I had the surgery I'm
just trying to protect us you don't need
that Tony wants to be a father but can't
separate himself from constantly putting
himself at risk for those that he loves
it's noble but it's also not right
according to pepper kids need a father
and not a galactic defender that sound
familiar
he actually is a father in fact all of
infinity war is about his relationship
to his kids and how in his quest to
quote unquote
save the galaxy he's willing to
sacrifice them for what he believes is
his destiny in order to take the stone
he must lose that which you love I
ignored my destiny once he is not a good
model of fatherhood he represents the
path that Tony is currently on at the
beginning of infinity war a father who
loses focus on his family for a greater
good and so Tony's arc in these two
movies as a foil to Thanos and as
someone who is set up in his first scene
talking about fatherhood his arc should
be about realizing what it takes to be a
good father so that he and Pepper can
move on and have a family at the end of
these movies and there are two key
pieces of evidence that support that
this is the arc that he's currently on
the first we've already seen losing
Peter Parker untighten Peter Parker is
his surrogate son you think it's a
coincidence that this story would put
him on Titan together that Peter would
die in Tony's arms it's so Tony can
experience the loss of a child the
knowledge that Ironman was powerless to
prevent the loss of someone that he saw
as a son someone that he loved and
appreciated but didn't spend enough time
with and then was just gone but notice
the only other person left untighten
with him nebulae she will be Tony's
second main turning point not only will
her robot parts be useful in getting the
two back to earth but as the abused
daughter of Thanos she'll be able to
show Tony what it's like to be the child
of a man who is bent on defending the
galaxy so in order to complete his arc
Tony has to survive he has to become a
father he has to learn from Thanos
mistakes and realize that you don't have
to be a literal hero
to be a super hero to your family as
such he'll give up being Iron Man but
live on to help supervise whatever in
the end he'll finally be able to fulfill
the wish from the end of age of Ultron
time for me to tap out
should take a page at a Barton's book
bill pepper a farm hope nobody blows it
up a simple life so there you have it as
far as smaller deaths I think that
nebula and war machine actually have a
good chance of biting the dust but
that's just a gut feeling
will I be right will I be wrong who do
you have bets on dying during the
endgame place your bets down in the
comments and then come back to brag
about how you got everything right next
week when the movie actually premiere is
protip you can just edit your comment to
make it look like you were right all
along
unfortunately for me though this video
lives on and can't be edited so what I'm
wrong I'm really wrong and I'm wrong
forever which kind of sucks but also
that's why I always remind you it's just
a theory
aa film theory and cut
[Music]